tonight i have the pleasure
and honor as soon as he appears of
introducing you to professor jan kershaw
who is presently the chair of modern
history
and the department of history at the
university of sheffield
in england professor kershaw is a fellow
of the alexander von humboldt
foundation as well as of the royal
historical society
and of the british academy is also
served as the historical and script
consultant
to the bbc's 1997 series
the nazis a warning from history
professor kirshaw is recognized as one
of the world's leading authorities
on hitler and the nazi regime
he began and as he assured us this
afternoon
is still quite active as a medievalist
but he became interested in the modern
era a generation ago
since that time he's published a number
of books
that can be best described as classic
scholarly works
on hitler and the nazi regime
among them are his groundbreaking works
on public opinion
perception and propaganda in the third
reich
their titles popular opinion and
political dissent
in the third reich a study of bavaria
published in 1983
and the hitler myth image and reality
in the third reich which came out in
1987.
his historiographical work entitled
the nazi dictatorship problems and
perspectives
of interpretation is a staple for
university courses
on the nazi regime and i understand that
a fifth edition
just came out at the end of last year
just in time for a course that i will
teach this summer
on the nazi regime during the course of
the last decade
professor kershaw was best known for his
profound
understanding and expert communication
of the history of the structures of a
society
and the interaction between society and
image
society and ideas has turned to
biography
his magnificent two-volume work on
hitler
a subject who sadly enjoys if that's the
right word
the broadest name recognition of any
20th century figure
weaves the history of a society with the
biography of an individual
in an effort to communicate grounded in
the most
meticulous research and thoughtful
analysis
how a modern sophisticated
industrialized nation
could follow a hate-filled scarcely
educated
outsider lacking political and social
connections
or even basic self-discipline
into as professor kershaw has so aptly
described it
in the title of the penultimate chapter
of his
second volume the abyss
i'm equally honored tonight to announce
that professor kershaw will be
interviewed by my colleague dr
joan ringelheim who is as most of you
know
the director of the oral history
department at the museum
and who is the mainstay of our an
evening with
program i have a few housekeeping notes
before we start each of you
has received an evaluation form when you
enter the theater
i would ask you please to take a moment
after the program to complete it
so that we might consider your thoughts
in planning
our future programming i would ask those
of you
who have questions for professor kershaw
to please
write them down on the cards provided
and pass them to a member of our staff
who will be collecting them
up and down the aisles at the
appropriate time
and now without further ado i'm going to
ask you to please
turn your attention to professor jan
kershaw
and dr joan ringelheim
good evening
there's a hitler quote that i thought i
would start with
gods and beasts that is what the world
is made of some ways you might hear a
lot of what hitler is
inside that one little sentence
ian kershaw quotes from george shot in
volume one
the secret of this personality namely
hitler
resides in the fact that in it the
deepest of what lies dormant
in the soul of the german people has
taken
shape in fully living features
that has appeared in hitler a living
incarnation
of the nation's yearning
and in the brief preface to hana aren't
totalitarianism she says the
subterranean stream of western history
has finally come to the surface and
usurped the dignity of our tradition
this is the reality in which we live i
have the sense
that these quotes provoke some of the
same questions
that ian kershaw has asked in his two
volumes
the questions that ian kershaw asks in
his two volumes
are essentially how is hitler
possible how is nationalism national
socialism possible
how is the holocaust possible who
and what are responsible is it hitler
is it germany is it both is it western
civilization
so what i hope we can do we're not going
to answer all the questions
obviously but what i hope we can do is
explore some of the
aspects of these questions that are so
interestingly
put out in in kershaw's book my first
question to you
is why did you decide to write
a biography of hitler
when there's such paucity of evidence
about his
personal and private life when there are
maybe
120 000 monographs including biographies
of hitler
and you are a social historian so why
did you do it
my initial instinct when i was asked by
the british publisher penguin to write
this biography was actually to decline
and i said well there are
at least two good biographies of hitler
that have been written those by my
countryman alan bullock and by the
german
historian yorkin fest and i just don't
think that
um i'm all that personally inclined to
write a biography either
so that was my initial reaction
um but in the meantime although
as you quite rightly say i began as a
social history of the third reich when i
started working on this
i had no particular fascination for
hitler i was
interested in the behavior and attitudes
and mentalities of the german people in
this period
but in as my work took shape on
nazi germany so i became then involved
in the structures of this regime
and how they operated i also um
took part in this famous or notorious
conference in the vicinity of london in
1979 where
all the german prominent historians were
there and
kicking hell out of each other and um it
was a fascinating
prospect to see this but it started me
wondering what was
going on here and why the there was such
a polarization of
interpretations about the third writing
about hitler in particular
and then also so what i'm describing now
is a way as to how i
got closer to this hitler biography and
then the further stage was then that i
was asked by
the british publishers longman to write
a little
profile of power of hitler not a
biography but simply an analysis
of his power and writing that then
sharpen the focus still further of
hitler's role
in this regime and the uh symbiosis
between hitler's personal role and the
uh attitudes and behavior of the german
people and also
the the precise position of hitler in
this
structure of rule and so all that really
shaped my interest more and more in
hitler but less from
a purely uh classical biographical point
of view which is the question you're
really posing
i think if you wrote we might call a
classical biography of hitler or just
about the man his personal
life and so on it'll be a very short
book indeed but here
um it was really this notion of
a biography of power i think that that i
was writing and
so ultimately on rereading bullock and
fest
i came to the conclusion that uh almost
half a century after bullock had written
his masterpiece
and almost quarter of a century after
fest had written his
very stylistic work in 1973 there was
indeed room for
another biography of hitler and one of
the reasons for this was actually
the the reason which will interest i
suppose many people particularly in this
audience that doesn't say how little
attention
was given in these two biographies these
two classical biographers of hitler
to the genesis of the holocaust
and um i had caused recently to re-read
bullock and or
parts of bulacan fest one more time and
i was again astonished at how little
space this took up
and if you just start from hitler and
don't place hitler in the social and
political context
then you see how little space this takes
up five or six pages in bullock and same
infest
my in my account there's a much wider
expanse given to these these these
terrible events
and therefore really i i came to
a biography hitler in a sense from the
wrong end from social history
but i think that gave me advantages in
the way that i approached it in trying
to place hitler
in the context of society and so my
question my initial question was really
to say
not how much did hitler need to do to
make this and that happen
but actually the reverse how little did
he need to do sometimes i found it
indeed he did a lot but
nonetheless the interesting the starting
question was this
this other one which therefore took me
into this relationship much more
strongly i think would have been the
case in the others
between hitler and the german society at
that time so do you then agree with one
of your reviewers that this is a social
biography
i'm not quite sure what it means but i
think i agree with it yes
can we talk for a second about sources
how
important were the gerbils diaries
that you found and why do you trust them
well the goebbels diaries were a very
imp uh
were a very important source for me
probably the most important
single most important source in the
writing of these two
uh these two volumes uh they are the
nearest thing that you have to a sort of
running commentary on hitler
over the best part of 20 years and
hitler as we know didn't have real
friends
and was incapable of human warmth and
normal
relationships but um
for many uh years in the 20s and 30s in
particular in the 1930s goebbels was
almost the nearest thing that he came to
having a friend amongst the nazi
leadership goebbels was on the scene a
lot
saw hitler on a daily basis and
therefore gobble was writing about this
which he always wrote it wrote down his
diaries on
the very next day so in contrast to
let's say spares memoirs which were
written
20 odd years after the end of the third
reich um
with all that had gone on and all that
he could then
really digest in terms of reaction to
this in the case of gobbles these were
immediate reactions on the next day now
of course it is true
that goebbels was writing these things
for posterity
and for his own place in posterity
afterwards a writing with therefore a
view to publication
so naturally one has to be very careful
in dealing with this material
uh it is colored through goebbels's own
um rendering of of events but
nonetheless i think it is the
uh task of the historian to be aware of
the biases of the sources but
nonetheless of course then
still where he or she thinks these are
uh a valuable account to use them and in
my
my view and not just my view the
goebbels
diaries do constitute a source of
absolute first rank
in dealing with the history of hitler
i i want to go to i'm not sure it's an
ongoing controversy anymore but i sort
of want to get it out of the way the
intentionalists and the functionalists
for those of you who don't know there
are those who believe that from the
beginning
hitler and the nazis intended to kill
the jews and that's identified in these
it's the intentionalist position
namely they intended it from the
beginning then there are those who
believe that the final solution
was slow incremental and
circumstantially
driven i think that's an appropriate way
to talk about the
functionalists or structuralists i have
the sense
in reading your two volumes and some of
my colleagues disagree with me
that you are in some sense both that you
are
an intentionalist ideologically with
respect to hitler
i don't mean that your ideology but in
with respect to hitler's ideology
but with respect to the practicality
with respect to
the policies and the actual actions you
are
a functionalist would that be a fair
um i think it probably is a fair um
a first summary of it uh the the the
debate the polarization
goes back to this conference or at any
rate the this conference that i
mentioned in 1979 brought this
polarization
sharply into focus and
i think that whatever their drawbacks
these uh two terms
of intentionalism and structuralism or
some people call it functions whichever
they
served a heuristic purpose let's say
this sharpened up the debate
and um my
work not just this these hitler volumes
in in a way but this this debate uh
interested me very much and the reasons
why there was this polarization and
preoccupied me a fair bit in the 1980s
and so on and um the some of the work
i've done including this profile in
power this short but was an attempt in a
sense to try to
overcome to transcend this polarization
neither of the sides of this taking to
their extreme seem to me to make very
much sense so
somewhere there had to be a type of
synthesis of these two positions and
the hitler biography is over a very big
canvas an attempt in a way to do that
so the question about um the way you put
it there and intentionally
in terms of hitler's aims and uh
structuralist or functions in terms of
the methods is
i think getting uh close to it
but in terms of the the aims
by one of the problems maybe just
intention the word intention but
by my own position is that i see hitler
as having
from the 1920s onwards a number of
a small number of fixed ideological
points which do not change and deviate
except for tactical reasons thereafter
but these tactical these sorry these um
ideological fixed points um
although they are unchangeable and can't
be
um can't be contradicted by people
within the nazi regime nonetheless
they are long-term goals rather than
what we understand as a
coherent political program so in terms
of the
the question the holocaust and the final
solution
you could probably say from the
beginning that hitler's ideology was
latently genocidal
it becomes more obviously genocidal as
time goes on
but the actual um final solution the
historical final solution as it comes
about
comes about through as as kyle schloyn
has put it at one time a twisted road
rather than a straight road
and there are many improvisations and
many deviations and so on along the way
but all within this ultimate goal of
what hitler put it in his first um
political statement of 9
september 1919 removal of the jews and
that meant of course different things to
different people at different times
and i think it did to hitler too so it
wasn't actually the notion of
uh in 1919 saying right now we are going
to exterminate physically the jews of
europe
in a coherent program which will follow
these steps but rather it was a
visionary goal which then gradually over
time
took concrete shape and became a
realizable political objective in that
sense
using in that way you have intentions
framed as these fixed ideological
long-term goals
and then a whole number of um of of
uh pushes and initiatives taken
towards these goals which then shape up
these goals until they become realizable
objectives
and that is therefore in a way a
synthesis of these two positions i think
let me start asking a series of
questions to see how you actually
craft that synthesis first i think
it would it was fascinating to me to
read about
hitler up to the age of about 30.
uh with a character that i began to
think if he was living today he would
have been a couch potato
with a lot of fantasies and doing
nothing
but you you know that may sound funny
but there
there is a way in which many of the
characteristics or
traits uh ways of living that he
shows through his early adult years
retain until the day he dies yes can you
talk about
what this who this character is what his
personality is like
yes um he i
he was being stretched imagination of
not an abnormal personality and i think
this abnormality goes back to these
early years
and there's been a recent book that's
appeared in germany which um
the author sent me a copy of it and said
it's it's not written
to contradict anything you're saying
your biography but rather to
um complement it or to add to it from
now a psychological
perspective now i'm not a psychologist
and i haven't no not really any trouble
with
psycho theories about hitler but in this
case it seemed to me that what the
psychological analysis suggested
fitted the historical evidence i say
instead of trying to reduce hitler's
psyche to some physical abnormality the
missing testicle
or whatever um in this case it was
actually looking at his character trace
and saying
how would a psychologist then analyze a
character like this and
the suggestion is that hitler falls into
a category of an individual who
could be seen to be schizophrenic
schizophrenia is a term that covers a
multitude of
uh forms of psychological behavior but
essentially
it matches the uh the non-psychological
picture i drew hitler in this first
volume let us say it is an enormous
abnormal gulf here between the
self-image from an early period onwards
and the reality
the self-image remind ourselves that uh
already walking around links with his
one friend he doesn't
this isn't a man who has friends easily
or forms any normal
human contacts walking around the lintz
with kubichak he's
coming up with fantasies about
redesigning the city he's only a boy at
the time it's
sort of unusual and uh when he goes off
to vienna
and of course amongst these fantasies
there's this fantasy of this girl
stephanie
that he sees on the streets of of of
lintz
and he doesn't even approach this girl
it's not that he tries to chat her up or
anything
she's just a distant vision but he um
he even writes her a letter and he tells
kubichuk about the house that he's
designing in which he and stephanie are
going to live and so
it's a strange sort of fantasy world
that he's living in and yet
when he then goes to vienna what happens
is that he
fails the entrance exam for the academy
of fine arts in vienna there's no
disgrace in that actually it was a hard
exam to pass
but hitler took it as a disgrace he
didn't tell his family about it
he didn't tell kubichak about it he kept
it to himself
he tried again the next year and failed
again well this was a almost certainly a
massive blow to his self-esteem
and he was left with feelings of shame
and this fits into this type of
individual or very secretive style of
individual who
harbors then lusting feelings of
humiliation or personal shame
often this is then
compensated for by somewhat peculiar
external behavior which is to try to
make a mark
and this is usually regarded by those
around this in the sort of individuals
forms of eccentricity which is actually
exactly how people in the men's home in
vienna
and then at the front in the first world
war regarded hitler
but after the first world war it seems
to me the first world war is the crucial
phase here
the hitler goes into that first world
war and he seems to have found what he's
looking for
and he's found an identity he's found
something to identify with he's found a
cause and a goal and in 1918 that's
absolutely shattered
and everything points to the fact that
hitler did undergo some form of trauma
at the end of the first war with the
news of germany's defeat and revolution
and the sense of deep-seated
this almost personalized sense of
humiliation
that germany had suffered on the end of
the the crushing of of
his beliefs of what he'd lived for to
them what he'd
the goals that he'd found and um this
when he then starts in in munich in 1919
uh speaking about this all at once he
finds he's got a resonance amongst the
audience you're finding people who's
listening who are listening to him
and this is now um therefore the
eccentric
is now finding his eccentricities are
now being accepted
as something which is abnormal but
abnormal in a positive way and the
german
or sections anyway in munich in the
munich bills initially
are then beginning to respond to this
and therefore this outward projection of
the inner feelings of shame which now
match up to the
um the the deep sen general sense of
humiliation at the defeat in
1918 this then finds hitler his audience
and people respond to that and
of course we have then this fight that
hitler becomes almost the persona
himself that he comes to life is
electrified when he's speaking before
a mass crowd in the munich beer halls
this is a projection outwards of this
and
the german people anyway elements of
them are now
sensing the same sort of shame which he
feels inwardly so i think
an abnormal personality of this sort
then and that's the type of
psychological depiction of what i think
we can understand in the layman's terms
that i've just
described for this abnormal um gap
between
self-image and uh and reality
and of course this gap was overcome by
what hitler then began to see as his
real achievements in the 1920s as people
started to take note of him
and as he said in mind come twice i
learned i could speak
by which he meant people were now
listening to him instead of thinking
what a crackpot
but if he's a schizophrenic and i wonder
if he doesn't have a personality
disorder more than schizophrenia he is
certainly a functioning schizophrenic
absolutely he's not absolutely and and
the the the point that the the
the two authors matusek is the name of
these characters i hope the book will be
translated into english at some stage
but
the point they're making is that people
who have this type of character disorder
are perfectly capable of what seems to
be normal behavior and um
so that they're not uh they're not
clinically insane at all but they are
but they normally have a personality
disorder so that
they can seem to be functioning not only
normally but actually very well in
certain areas and of course hitler had a
a very uh a remarkable memory he was
very quick-witted and sharp and so on
it's not that he was
uh he was in any way
um slow or
or mentally um
the the the this problem caused him to
be
somehow non-functional in any way in any
mental way
not only not at all um
you say he lacks discipline from
beginning to end
yes um
what is it in 1919 do you think that
brings him to be able to write this
letter
answering gimlich which brings out the
first time that we see his anti all of a
sudden there's this vicious disgusting
anti-semitic racist stuff that comes out
of him how does
do you have an explanation or does one
simply have the chronology
um no the explanation links on to what
i've just been saying in a way i think
that um
hitler was living in vienna at the time
that he was living was
uh as good as certainly um
strongly anticipating when he was in
vienna i wouldn't go along with brigitte
hamaniaru
suggest that he wasn't anticipating at
that time that
that this man in this place at this time
was was not anti-semitic it's hard to
believe
but it was probably a nice time more a
conventional anti-semitism i think the
the paranoid of pathological
anti-semitism
is a product of the end phase of the
first world war and the
immediate years thereafter that's an
inference it it can't
be 100 proven but it's a nobody who knew
hitler before
1919 really remarks upon his
anti-semitism
and afterwards this is unmistakable so
there's something said for the fact that
the year from the end covering the end
of the war through to the summer of 1919
was they really
really formative period in turning
hitler the conventional anti-semite into
hitler the
pathological anti-semite and
hitler was not alone in in
this last phase of the first world war
between about 1916 and 1918
in starting to turn his attention to the
jews
as the apparent cause of germany's
mounting disaster in the first world war
so on the on the nationalist
right nationalist imperialist right in
germany often through
calculated propaganda such as put out by
the
short-lived fatherland party in 1917
a party which within a short time got a
big membership
this was membership this this party also
related the the jews specifically
to germany's problems in the first world
war
and accused the jews of um one another
shirking their duties shooting and
shirking their patriotic duties accuse
the jews of being
a war have been war profiteers and
racketeers and so on
uh on the other hand accused the jews of
fermenting unrest at terms
all these things that we see in hitler
were more widely spread
by this extreme nationalist right in the
last phase of the war
hitler has a tendency in everything he
touches to radicalize it to take it to
the absolute extreme
and he does that in this case too so i
think hitler was picking up
quite commonplace sentiments on the
nationalist
uh right in the last phase of the war
many experiences in munich
the revolution which was
more radical in munich than it was in
the rest of germany
and uh then in april 1919 the so-called
council's republic this short-lived
uh soviet-style republic the leaders of
which happened to be jews
so the whole thing seemed to fit into
place so i think what hitler
is doing here is finding scapegoats
an explanation for this personal trauma
on this national trauma national
humiliation
of 1918 and he is not alone in saying
the reason for this is that germany's
been betrayed from within and the main
agents of that betrayal are the jews
so i think this is the real beginning of
this pathological
anti-semitism and then immediately after
the first world war
um this type of really rabid
anti-semitism was quite commonplace
in the beer halls on the streets of
munich in precisely the
setting that hitler found himself in so
once more he was on the one hand
affected by the surroundings and on the
other hand
found that he was able to expound this
anti-semitism more expressively and more
vehemently than anybody else and
therefore they
the response was all the more
forthcoming as a consequence of that so
i think that
that was the phase where hitler really
turns into the hitler of history the
hitler that we that we know in terms of
this
absolutely dominant anti-semitism and i
think if you take it right through then
what you could say is that
in hitler's entire life from there
onwards from 1918
right down to the bunker in 1945 the key
thing driving him was the
need to avoid any possible repetition of
the capitulation
and the shame that followed of 1918 who
were the people to blame for this
the jews in his warped and perverted
sense of um of of uh what had happened
and so
the rest in a way follows logically from
that that the
war which he knew was needed to
overcome this humiliation by making
germany the most powerful
nation in in europe and possibly later
in the world
that this uh war had to be at one of the
same time
a war against the jews
let me see if i can do this next
question putting together a couple of
things
at one point in volume one you talk
about hitler
i don't think it's specifically about
anti-semitism but you talk about him as
a consummate
actor now there are historian
biographers who have said
on the one hand he was only an actor on
the other hand he was an actor who
believed in his part which was bullock's
later view of himself and i'm wondering
whether
when you speak about his getting a
response when he finds out
i can speak i have a place because he
had no
future it would appear is there some way
in which the passions get
exacerbated exaggerated because there's
a response
so he creates something for this public
who seems to be responding to it
and then he ends up believing it or does
he start out believing it i mean i don't
know what yes i think he starts out
believing it and the response that he
gets
then um confirms this inner sense of
belief i think one of the reasons he was
so
effective as a speaker when basically
what he was saying was the same thing
that many other
people were saying at the same time was
that
he did speak with this innermost passion
that
reflected a deep moving belief in him
it wasn't um it wasn't made up he wasn't
a good actor it's true
and he was of course the supreme
propagandist but being a propagandist
and being an ideologue
are not mutually exclusive things first
of all and secondly i think
being a propagandist can be even
enhanced if you do believe the
propaganda that you're putting out
rather than just manufacturing something
so hitler in my estimation was certainly
not
the unprincipled opportunist the simple
manipulator that bullock portrayed him
as in the first of his books in 19
written in 1952 but he was much more
the propagandist who believed his own
propaganda from the innermost
core and just going back to it of course
the the gemly
letter of 1919 which you asked about
reflected the fight that hitler by this
time in september 1919
rationalized i think the feelings which
he
had been harboring and been developing
until he got
actually a coherent um coherent analysis
in his own mind
for what had gone wrong and hence he
came to the conclusion in that letter
the
striking conclusion as he said in that
letter that
emotional anti-semitism isn't enough
and it will never bring the answer it
brings pogroms with it but those will
never provide the total answer what you
need he said
is the anti-semitism of reason
by which he meant then a rational
program for removing jews because
he went on to say in it that the the
final goal
of any national government in germany
must be
the removal of jews altogether so i
think it was by this
this state that he had actually
rationalizes his hatreds but the hatreds
were there inside him
before the rationalization came and
before
the sense arrived that he was now
getting such a
wonderful response from the audiences
that he was preaching to in the munich
bills and so on
when you talk about uh europe after
world war one
you suggest that there are many
anti-democratic tendencies
all over europe people looking for
strong leaders
do you see that germany more than other
countries
wished this or it just was this
confluence of
is there something more deeply embedded
in the german culture as you understand
it that would bring this out i think
there was a strand of the german
political culture
which became which was there um before
the first world war
but not the dominant strand and then
after the first world war
for the reasons we've already been
inducing for
because of the traumas that followed
that
and in the conditions now of a new
democracy which was
far from uh generally accepted that it
says the state system was not generally
accepted in these conditions
the um thirst for
an authoritarian leader
then became more widespread and more
acceptable in
ever widening sections of the population
and that then latched on to
certain strands in germany which i think
were peculiar as you said
these tendencies of course in certain
senses could be seen elsewhere and after
all it's in italy
that the first um fascist dictatorship
comes about in 1922 but the
in in germany i think what you have are
already
in a sense almost um
there's almost a mythical component
in the search for leadership that goes
back into the
the the myth of the reich that's already
in existence before
the first world war of the
the sense of heroic leadership which was
pinned onto
bismarck and before bismarck frederick
the great
and the sense also in germany that
uh the the german people
the folk was not just different from
other peoples but
actually superior in all sorts of ways
in cultural senses and
as i say there are many there were many
groupings in germany that didn't accept
there's only one strand of the political
culture and of course the
liberal strands and social democratic
strengths and so on
but one strand was this and this strand
became after the conditions after the
first world war
more prevalent and i remember one thing
that
uh one one quotation that i provided in
the first volume which i think just sums
this up
and this was in 1920 or 21 i think
before hitler had ever been heard of
really
and it was from a neo-conservative
writer not from a nazi
rabble-rouser and this said that in this
divided society that we have and this
this political system that is
filled with contemptible political
politicians
what we are yearning for is a great
leader who will come and this great
leader must
be at one of the same time a statesman
a warrior and a high priest
and it's an interesting combination when
you reflect on it
and the final part of that the high
priest demonstrates also a type of
pseudo-religious component that's built
into this expectation
of the great leader who come who will be
a statesman not a politician like the
parliamentary politicians who will be a
great
warrior to match up the militaristic
element and
then finally as i said to be a high
priest symbolizing really
the almost belief system which is going
to be invested
in that future so i think in these in
these things you have
um within the general characteristics of
um
of readiness to place trust in
um in an authoritarian leadership and
dislike of democratic tendencies which
as you say quite widespread in europe at
the time you have some particular
specific
components that help to shape up the
character
i think of the authoritarian personality
that the
the germans were looking for at the time
let me ask you about the january 30th
1939
threat i want to ask you about a
peculiar part of it namely
the paragraph that comes before the
actual threat when he says
i've often been a prophet in my life i
was generally laughed at
during my struggle for power the jews
primarily received with laughter my
prophecies that i would someday assume
the leadership of the state etc
i suppose then they the resounding
laughter of jewry
in germany is now choking in their
throats what is this
um is there
is this some demonstration of a kind of
fear
that demonstrates the fear that he has
of jews and the power
of laughter uh to demonize him
yes i think it does i think you you
you're right with that you hit the nail
on the head i think it does reflect an
alt an underlying fear of jews and
hitler
and it also reflects going back to what
we're saying a minute or two ago
this sense of inner um
in our lack of um self-esteem or
something that i'm being left out i mean
there's a sort of interesting notion he
repeats that on a number of occasions
that
they've been laughing at him and somehow
these people whose
own self-esteem is greatly undermined
basically murder of someone like hitler
but
where where they they are very sensitive
towards people laughing at them and so
on
and hence there is this element all the
time running through this of revenge
of now getting my own back on the people
who've been taken out of me and at the
same time this feeling that they
nonetheless hold enormous power in their
in their in their grasp
right um i'm going to try to combine
three questions at once
he has a very strange leadership style
uh that can be encompassed by the
principal working
working with for the uh towards the
fuhrer this
organization of the state is
disorganized
most of us i think normal folk think
about the nazis they knew what they
wanted they did what they wanted they
had it all planned out
it was very clear um
you say something quite different that
the very principle
of working towards the fuhrer um
is a disorganization principle it's an
it's a principle of struggle and
competition
now why is this so attractive he doesn't
have
office hours not that you ever thought
he had office hours but he doesn't have
office hours he doesn't meet with a
cabinet he doesn't meet regularly even
doing the war
with with a war board or some
you know it's it's very strange and it
struck me in the course of reading your
book and i don't know if this is right
that there's some way in which you are
pulling
back from talking about how attractive
he is to people
that when spirit says i couldn't even
see him
in 1943 very often because if i'd see
him too often i would get
under his spell and i felt as i was
reading the book
that i couldn't feel the spell
and that you didn't want to portray it
um yes i hadn't consciously done that
but there may be something in it
i'm not actually trying to shy away from
the fact that hitler did have
quite extraordinary um
attractiveness for appeal for those
around him and
albert speer of course is the classical
example of somebody who almost has a
love affair with hitler i don't think
it's
requited actually uh as such i mean uh
uh it it's it's more one-sided than
spare will
actually i think uh claim in in his
memoirs
but of course um as we all know
um uh i think maybe it was mr clinton
who said it and he should know power is
an aphrodisiac
and um uh
and uh in i think we get into
presidential policy um
but it but in in the in this in this
context therefore
uh hitler was someone now after night
they had this
obviously this aura of power around him
and that aura makes
people then very attractive and have
this enormous appeal and
makes them somehow mystical but what i
was very anxious to do
in in both of these volumes in a way was
to demystify hitler wherever possible
and
get a little bit behind the mask because
hitler was
he he played i think i said at the
beginning of the first one he played to
perfection
throughout his period as leader of the
nazi party and their leader of journey
played to perfection this role of the
fuhrer
and um spear of course hadn't made his
own career on this had his own powers
his own advantage in massive advantages
from this and he was
one of a whole number who who was sucked
into it in in this way willingly of
course
um adhered to this and found hitler uh
attractive but i i wasn't trying to play
down
that appeal but rather to see
nonetheless through this
notion of working towards the fuhrer how
the mechanics of this operated and how
this in itself could be attractive so
that
um it doesn't necessarily of course have
to be
totally disorgan leader total
disorganization
um you could even say in certain senses
that
the modern management actually rests a
little bit on this principle of um
setting the the target goals the what
are called the mission statements or the
other aims and objectives and then
freeing up
the possibilities for under managers to
work towards these goals and in a way i
think you can apply that analogy to what
hitler's doing here
he stands for these absolutely
inflexible mission
aims and mission is not a wrong term for
this it's a religious term of course and
hitler himself uses it time and time
again he speaks about his
sendong in german his mission and these
goals that i mentioned before making
german the greatest
power in europe uh acquiring living
space at the expense of the soviet union
and removal of the jews
these goals were not negotiable they
were the mission names they were the
overriding parameters of action but
beneath that
how to interpret those how to push these
forward that was people were given great
freedom to do that
and actually that's enormously
attractive in all sorts of ways
um and just what i think hitler was
doing here was just
unleashing enormous energies and saying
right you want to do this
do it and in certain circles that's
phenomenally attractive that
and it's not by chance that two of the
two of the
professional groups who were most
nursified and most attracted by this
system were engineers and doctors
these are groups who now were given
absolutely free scope to
devise whatever grandiose
plans they wanted to do and doctors who
are normally held back in terms of what
they can experiment on we're now given
license to do practically what they
wanted so
there were groups and these in these
professional uh
organizations who found this enormously
attractive and that's we're not talking
now about uh
about nazi thugs and so on but
professional well-trained professional
groupings in germany so i think in this
way too functionally
it could be this this working towards
the fear idea is a way of trying to see
how
uh a type of relationship between hitler
setting the
overall goals and how people then push
along the
dynamic and the radicalization of this
regime by being given the scope to do it
uh so hitler wasn't um he wasn't a sort
of
control freak in the way that styling
was of having to
shower down dictats from one eye all the
time but nonetheless he could be
confident
that the main goals that had been set
here were being adhered to that nobody
was contradicting those
so he's always on message but he's also
distant
yeah yeah and the distance was the
distance was also
in a way necessary because um
this nimbus this aura of the great
leader
meant that he could not be sucked into
day-to-day politics
so there was also a functional event of
this there was also of course an
ideological element in that
hitler's belief in um
crude social darwinism let's say that
the the the stronger will always win out
and deserves to
awesome man that he was prepared to sit
back and let his
underlings fight it out amongst
themselves but the point i was making
before about the functional necessities
also also has to be born in mind that
hitler's reaction when people would come
and say well
he uh he he wants to do this and i want
to do that and so on
and and there's a conflict there which
can't easily be reconciled is
go away and sort it out not this is the
answer to it and
that was one way of ensuring ultimately
he'd always been on the side of the the
one that won
um and also it meant that he was aloof
from the fray he was not a
a conventional politician was dragged
into the nitty-gritty of politics
you know hegel's statement about a hero
is no hero to his valet because not
because the hero's not a hero but
because the valley is of la
in this case it sounds like the hero is
a hero
to his valet and that's because the
ballet is a ballet
i think i follow that i didn't anymore
let's talk about the war and the
integration
of holocaust and the genocide of the
jews and others
inside the war there is a way in which
you describe and it seems perfectly
reasonable that
war is the quintessential struggle
for hitler sometimes i wonder if it's
because war was so exciting to him in
world war one that was where he sort of
began his
real future um
but you also say that he has very little
involvement in terms of policy decisions
policy decisions and he sets the goals
and other people are supposed to
figure it out but he stays very close to
the war effort
he becomes the commander sort of the
daily commander-in-chief when he's not
general and i began to wonder
as i thought about what you were saying
is how come
he didn't trust the generals
to win the war but he trusted people
to murder why was there this
and was it because the war in fact at
that point
was more important because if he won he
could do whatever he wanted yeah
yes i think that that's right to put it
in
in that way that the the war for hitler
was the
the absolute overriding um
key um set of events which he needed to
control and this was
what he was about winning this war but
as i
was saying beforehand it would in my
view be a mistake to
separate out away from that the
um the war against the jews it was part
and parcel of the same thing
um but in the case of the of um
anti-jewish policy and also
other aspects of domestic policy and
um discriminatory policies towards
minorities and so on
hitler could be well assured here
that these were in the safe hands of his
most trusted
lieutenants namely uh himmler and
heidrich and so on
in the ss leadership in the ss he had
the organization there which was
set up even to be the um
the organization to implement this
ideology and
hitler unlike stalin was not distrustful
of those immediately around him
so that uh hitler accepted that himmler
would do the dirty work for him
and of course the others around him
would do the dirty work for him he was
confident in other words with regards to
um to race policy that he had the people
there to do this
and he didn't need to check up all the
time what they were doing and so on
in the case of uh military events
he was not confident because there he
had the
army and later on he was they would say
um
about starway and it was stalin was
absolutely right to wipe out his
military leadership at the time he
thought stalin was absolutely crazy to
do so but
later on he said good for starring that
he did this i wish i'd been in a
position to do the same thing
because the military leadership were the
people that he always regarded as
not his real type these were the
prussian
officers and aristocrats and so on not
the
characters that he could entrust with
this and perversely as the
german war machine uh
attained its greatest triumphs in
particular the in the west offensive of
1940 with this
astonishing victory over france hitler's
contempt for the military actually rose
and as you many of you will know of
course the attack on france in
1940 the western offensive in general on
the attack on france
was carried out by a strategic
strategic plan which hitler had largely
taken over from
manstein but it was a plan which went
against the
original plans drawn up by the military
leaders
leadership in the um in the general
staff
and hitler his own instinct was that
this initial plan was to orthodox and
uh not not really going to bring about
the surprise that he wanted
and he picked he seized on manchester's
plan pushed it through
adopted it and indeed it brought about
this fantastic
victory in just a short time in france
so that increased his contempt then for
the generals
who had actually gone against this
military plan and he'd been proven right
and the meanwhile of course the
adulation was showered on him his
megalomania went into the
stratosphere and this was a fatal
conflict then
as the war progresses then into this
in into the um the phase where the first
setbacks occur already
in the autumn of 1941 in russia and um
it's at that time of course and the
first real military crisis of this
regime has had in the
um in the late months of 1941 that
brachish the
commander in chief of the of of the arm
of the army
is then sacked and hitler now
takes over the actual day-to-day running
of the army as the commander-in-chief
it's
absolutely amazing development and
hitler becomes the
is the only head of state in this war
who actually takes over the tactical
arrangements
of the of of his army and even stalin
recognized that he was made made crap
well he didn't acknowledge it it's true
but he
inwardly recognized that he made crass
mistakes in 1941
and started pulling back and leaving it
to the professionals hitler's line is
the opposite one
he takes more and more in some because
he thinks as soon as i let anybody else
who solve this they'll make a mess of it
i'm the only one who can rescue germany
so his um this this approach becomes
absolutely fatal of course for germany's
chances
as soon as the war turns from this
blitzkrieg style war where germany
can hold the initiative down to a
nutritional defensive wall where you
need the expertise of the generals and
by this stage
it will nothing but concern for these
generals
so is there a decision to kill the jews
you probably have the date
the latest of all the historians that i
know
you say that it's july 1942
when it's fully moving because you don't
see that there's one
actually almost nobody sees it there's
one decision that it is incremental
but you're quite late in terms of the
what you think is the eve said your life
order too yeah
that's what i saw okay well you've read
the book since i have
it's really uh no no your language is
it's really underway it's not that there
isn't mass
murder and i think that that's a very
interesting question when does mass
murder become genocide is clearly mass
murder from the start
well i mean yes uh well my line is here
that the genocidal intent is there
plainly visible i have a chapter that's
called marks of a genocidal mentality
which is in the aftermath of the
uh so-called ice crystal pogrom of the
november 1938.
so i think there you can see a genocidal
intent
whatever the uh you can read into
earlier
comments i think by that time you can
see it as genocidal
um but what does genocide mean at that
time it
essentially means i think for a long
period from 1939 into 1941 even
pushing the jews into some horrendous
reservation where through starvation
being worked to death or other for
malnutrition disease and so on and so
forth they will
die out over a period of time genocide
not the actual genocide which came about
that is the i think the the mentality
which is shaping up
hitler and the ss leadership and so on
in 1940 you see it quite
plainly i think in also things like
madagascar plan
and they're looking around for different
ways to
bring about this so-called solution to
the the jewish question
now when you go into the um the actual
preparations for
uh operation barbarossa the attack on
the soviet union
you begin then to move into a different
phase where
um real physical killing
of large numbers of jews is now being
envisaged in the
in in the immediate future now as we
know when the einsatzgruppen go into
the soviet union uh the killing
is in the initial phases almost um
completely confined to male jews
um there is a a tremendous escalation
that takes place in
i would say that's uh already genocidal
but it's
not the complete genocide that we have
later on obviously
a massive escalation in the summer of
1941
following a series of um private
meetings between himmler and hitler
when the number of police units in the
east is now
increased dramatically remember that
when the einsatzgruppen go in
there are about 3 000 people in these
are in these four einsatzgruppen
if your aim is to bring about a total
genocide even in the east you're not
going to do it with 3 000 people
but in the summer of 1941 the numbers
were dramatically increased
and that was tantamount to the decision
how to kill jewish women and children as
well as men and now instead of having
the figures in 1 000 here and 800 there
and 1200 they're horrendous figures in
their own right
but now you're getting into the figures
which come in it in the baba yar
massacre of september
33 000 in two days and so on and
proportionately a larger
a larger percentage in um if you
if you count up the victims in september
1941 for example
um are women rather than men so there
has been a change there so that's a big
genocidal shift
then you get the deportation of the
german czech and austrian jews which
hitler agrees to
in september 94 to under these areas
where genocide is raging
where there's no place to put the
the jews deported as we see in mods in
poland and that immediately
results then in the decision to find a
killing installation in western poland
which turns out to be a culminal
death camp you have jews being then
assassinated i mean
being exterminated in large numbers then
german jews now were sent out to riga
and kavanaugh
and so on so in that autumn then you're
entering now into a new escalatory phase
of killing which is turning the genocide
now of the
against the russian i guess the soviet
jews now
into uh wider genocide but still we
haven't reached the
the final point of this development and
there are lots of on this overall
central remit lots of
uh regionalized uh genocides which are
taking place
the next stage i think is then the um
the period
surrounding the uh the declaration of
war on the usa
by germany where there's another major
escalation that follows
immediately after hitler's speech to his
party leaders on the 12th of december
1941
this is when hans frank tells his people
that i've just been to berlin talking to
these characters in berlin and saying
well what are we supposed to do about
your jews liquidate them yourselves and
so on so
this is now it's not a it's not a
coherent a clear
order in the way that we normally
understand such an order it's not like
the orders that hitler gave out in
the military arena and so on but it is a
tantamount to an order now that the time
has come to
deal with the jews in this total way and
that leads on then to the evans
conference only a few weeks later on the
20th of january 1942
when the organizational framework for
this is now determined
um and shortly after that now but into
the spring of 1942
we have then the the extension of the
deportations to
to western europe so that it seems to me
that there are a number of phases of
escalation in this
and are trying to look for one single
order on one particular day whether it's
the summer of 41 on the ultimate 401 or
whenever
it's probably wrong and to try to
suggest that there was
a coherent fuhrer order in the sense
that
we understand an order is probably also
wrong that
here we have a series of authorizations
by hitler
of ever more radical escalatory steps
that's how
it seems to me the evidence fits it and
in a way
the the scale of what is going on this
mind-boggling scale of the genocide
against the jews
is such that in one way even common
sense i think suggests when you
reflect on it that it probably was
incapable of being decided on one day at
one moment but rather had to take
shape gradually like that because it was
beyond even the
the monumentality of even the nazi
leadership to
to comprehend such a a sort of
programmed event it had to take gradual
shape i think and
so when the step was entertained into
genocide i would say was with the
invasion of the soviet union
and then a number of escalatory steps
bringing that genocide into the
a total genocidal program into the
complete
so-called final solution to use nazi
parlance or the holocaust as we
have come to know it my last question
has to do with
hitler's view of his own people
believing that there is a triumph of the
will
and if you have enough will you can win
and if you can't win you deserve to be
destroyed so he didn't actually
care a wit what happened to germany or
germans
if they didn't win which also seems a
little bit contradictory to his not
wanting to
well maybe the worst thing is to
capitulate not not to simply lose
um but this if that's true about him
and about the nazi party in some way but
perhaps more true of him is there some
way in which
his nazism was suicidal
in the end it was only about
death that either you won or you lost
there was never compromise there was
nothing in between
and if heaven help us they had killed
all the jews
they never would have stopped killing
because struggle had to go on forever
absolutely right that is absolutely
right a very perceptive
comment and i think there was no end to
this um
that uh if you look at the so-called
general plan for the east the general
plan aust of 1941 then again you see
that
the killing of the jews although the
jews were the number one hate target
the killing of the jews was only the
beginning of what they had in mind for
the
deportation of 31 million
slavs mainly over the next 25 years most
of whom would have been
condemned to death effectively in the
arctic waste of siberia or somewhere
so this was a regime that could never
stop and in that very
sense as you quite rightly
point out there there was almost a
self-destructive component a
suicidal component i think that there
was a suicidal component in hitler's own
personal makeup i mean they
this is a sort of prima donna type who
who
uh immediately then when he didn't get
his way then threatened to kill himself
he did so on many occasions and
unfortunately didn't carry it out until
30th april 1945. but um but
they this but but this is this is this
was part of his makeup and this
this lack of compromise again it's an
extraordinary thing in
in a politician and a successful
politician that
normally politics is built upon
compromise and here's a man who makes
his career out of no compromise
why why could he do that because his
opponents were
always weak ones in inside germany
before 1933
later on his international enemies were
weak right down until
the uh the war against the soviet union
in 1941.
once that war goes wrong then going back
to my starting point about the
the strength of this conviction be no
repetition of the capitulation of 1918
what was then left you couldn't hitler's
line was
no negotiations except from a position
of strength where was that strength
going to come from in 1943 especially in
1944
nowhere so consequently he was left with
the
realization he had a greater sense of
reality than many people think he
he was well aware of the fact that this
war was going downhill at a tremendous
rate of knots
but nonetheless what rings true
are his comments repeated in these in in
these later months of the war
that we will never capitulate we will go
down in flames first
but we'll take a world with us so this
is a regime which even for
authoritarian systems or dictatorships
is extraordinary
in the sense that it has a death wish
and the people around hitler himmler
girling goebbels ribbon shop
and co let alone the military leadership
they're all saying well why don't we
actually try and find a way out of this
mess
not just sort of go no this was actually
the way no way out sought
rather go down and this is just
extraordinary it reflects
this inability of this regime to
or hitler personally to contemplate
survival
except from a position of strength and
hence to go back to original point
this in this phase when the german
people are no longer capable of winning
the war
in his view they are absolutely
dispensable like everything else around
him was dispensable
they deserve to go under because they're
not strong enough
and ultimately therefore he had this
sense of
horrendous statement a comment that he
made that in i think it was
february march 1945 to one of his
generals when he said
the german people deserve to
go under because they're not worthy of
me
megalomania has reached the point now
where the german people having struggled
through these six years of war now
deserve to be defeated because not
worthy of the man who's
led them into the war in the first place
um
can people collect questions and while
you're doing so i'll ask
you a question run down so we can get
the people's quest
in the beginning of volume one you say
the legacy of hitler belongs to all of
us
this is hitler's century and his
dictatorship quote amounted to the
collapse of modern civilization
it showed us what we are capable of what
do you want us to take away
from this
i think um
i think it was solzhenitsyn who said
somewhere that there's a capacity for
evil in every individual
capacity for evil in offer evil deeds in
every individual
it's a very pessimistic view of
humankind but i i fear it's one that i
share
um and what prevents us from doing that
basically are the the structures and
mentalities in which we are
acclimatized but those structures and
mentalities can
disappear and be destroyed and when they
are
and nothing holds us back i think we are
capable many of us are doing
fairly horrendous things so i think what
the hitler regime shows us is what
is possible when all those constraints
are
removed and that's really if we're
looking for
moral or political lessons then i think
those are the ones to to bear in mind
that these constraints
um which are often seemingly irksome to
us in all sorts of ways we
were irritated by all sorts of things
about our respective political systems
but ultimately
a democrat democratic system um
provides such constraints and a
democratic system i think
can actually fail as well it's not
something which we
necessarily need to take for granted and
so these things i think politically and
morally
are perhaps um things that we can bear
in mind
as a reflection on the terrible hitler
dictatorship
um this is a completely this is not a
question for you this is a
someone's lost their keys in the
audience
they can pick them up where the books
are sold don't worry it'll be okay
and as long as not more than one of you
have lost their keys and we don't know
um did hitler understand
uh communist ideology economic
so it looks like the economics of
communist ideology and did he associate
uh jews with communism uh the second
part is um is very easy to answer that
yes
of course he did and the um from 1919
onwards
this was then ever present in his mind
that jews
were the um the backbone of
bolshevism as well as they were
the backbone of capitalism so they
controlled moscow just as they
controlled wall street and the city of
london
so this is an extraordinary game i'm
actually point about power there's an
extraordinary
image of uh uh built upon demonology of
jews are so powerful they control every
aspect of things so
this isn't actually uh just a
conventional
um attack against some real enemy with
him but a phantasm of uh
jews who control uh the whole lot but
the question was about the communism and
yes
this link of jews and bolsheviks the
jews and communists was
there from 1919 onwards and hitler's
thinking
and more or less ever present in his
rhetoric in the years that followed
that um in the question of his
understanding of um
of uh communist economics he had nothing
really but the crudest
understanding of any economics um but he
did
uh understand uh
his his his under his police
geopolitical ideas were also built upon
this crude sense of
of economics as well which was one
essentially resting upon art or turkey
you grabbed the land and then you
exploited it
and you didn't depend upon the vagaries
of into
international capitalism in the case of
the communist
economy what he uh regarded as anathema
was the
taking away of initiative and of
the profit motivation from this so again
it was an extraordinary crude sense of
that he didn't read
uh in communist economics or anything
about them but what is feeding was that
if you have a society which levels
everything down and which takes away
um takes away the the carrot takes away
the chances of
of doing well and takes away the the
composite competition element
then you are doomed so in this way too
this was a
a way on the economic front of seeing
this system as one which was total
anathema and
one that needed to be needed to be
eradicated
you've explained why hitler began to
express anti-semitic views
how do you explain nazi victimization of
gays gypsies polls russians
does this reflect hitler's belief or
broader german societal attitudes
yes it it it well it didn't
directly reflect hitler's own
um his own thinking as far as i'm aware
hitler never said anything about the
gypsies i might be corrected on that but
i don't think that he said anything
directly about
gypsies uh yet nonetheless of course
gypsies were
were also murdered in vast numbers
during the war
um but what what i think we have in this
discrimination
generally is actually again something
close to the heart of this
regime what this regime was about and
what this philosophy
was about was creating an ethnically
pure nation and
this ethnically pure nation which uh
was given the sort of appellation of a
national community folks command shaft
was one which got its the the fox
commander the national community got his
definition by those groups who were
excluded from it
and hence jews were the
uh public enemy number one but there
were many other groups who simply didn't
fit into this
image of the ethnically pure national
community and those groups had to be
cut out of it and therefore as we were
talking about the
the war and the um
the pursuit of victims continuing what
we mentioned it's a minister to a girl
so we can see in this sense that the
regime can't stop it finds every new
groups there to be
discriminated against pushed onto the
margins and
removed from this society and this was
not
again a result of dictators from hitler
do this do that do the other but this
was
partly the uh in good measure actually
sub-organizations within this regime
which were finding their own target
groups and prominent amongst them was
the ss police
organization which when you set up an
organization as you
all know that organization finds things
to organize and find things to
expand its own operations and this is
one thing that's happening with these
target groups so that you're finding the
ss actually
looking for new target groups and
expanding their own operations that's
the way they get more money more
positions
greater power and so on and so forth so
there's an element of functionality
that's based into the
ideology of this too so that precisely
at the time in 1935
6 when the concentration camps seem to
have done their
original dirty weather say they've dealt
with the real enemies political enemies
of that regime
and they're now they're reduced to i
think a figure of about three and a half
thousand people in there there's no
reason no logical reason why they
shouldn't now be
so shut down but is that precise at that
time that
the ss start to build them up now to
take in lots of different targets
including homosexuals who
um all at one following the the room
puts in the so-called rumpage in 1934
where the
allegations of homosexuality have been
put against the leaders of the
stormtroopers there
and given us a moral cover for this um
for this
uh the action that hitler took to remove
this this thought on his side
following that then again the the ss
seized upon the chance now our
homosexuality is in
now in terms of in in by that i mean
in in terms of a target group and so
all at once then they start their the
their
their push now to um to remove
homosexuals and so on so
we have here therefore an ideology aimed
at national uh
national community resting upon racial
purity
which then opens the door to countless
ethnic groupings and other other groups
that can be discriminated against so
the search for the artist ceases and
that became state becomes taken up in
organizational fashion
by the ss in particular and the police
apparatus in general
how do you explain the attack on the
ussr especially so late
in the year i guess so close to winter
22nd new jersey i'm sorry i was um
the the initial idea
had been to um to
attack in in may that was the original
original notion of the attack in may but
um in fact
along the way there the um the the need
was
it was imperative that the um that
certain troops were now diverted down to
the uh the balkans to deal with the
problems there
that had suddenly manifested themselves
in yugoslavia
many of these troops were not ready for
um for action
in the soviet union in in the may
and the operation was was
uh deferred therefore until until june
and there were other
logistical reasons too why things
couldn't be put together in time for may
so there are a number of quite uh
straightforward
logistical considerations which push
back the attack
on the soviet union from may to
the third week in june
sometimes one has to think if he had not
done that
what would have happened and had he when
he realized that he was going to lose in
the soviet union if he had negotiated
with
stalin what would have happened to
europe there was no
possibility before june
1941 hitler allowed jews to leave
germany
actually it's earlier than that i think
what what changed his views you
you do say in your book and some people
have disagreed with it
that he had to be prodded to have the
jews where a jewish star in 41 and to
deport the jews from germany
so what was it prodding or was it from
him
yes i mean first of all um
just clarify in the 1930s the policy
insofar as there was a coherent policy
was a policy of forced
immigration that's effectively expulsion
from germany
once the war had begun that policy then
shifts you see that already in the
in the policy in poland in the after
invasion of poland the policy shifts now
to uh the removal of jews then to
um this sort of horrendous reservation
idea
that then takes different shape and uh
it
first of all is the the idea is is it a
part of poland then it moves to
madagascar for a while then it moves the
idea is the
um beyond the euros or in the arctic
ways or something like this
so there are a number of stages of this
this reservation idea but it's no longer
then immigration and there's the
after the war begins there's the merest
trickle of immigration
of german jews until it is finally
stopped in october 1941.
now when we come to the deportation of
the raichud of the german austrian and
czech jews in
with the decision given in the in
mid-september 1941
that decision was given by hitler but
the
pressure to take that decision was
coming from a number of those
in the next level down lower than hitler
it came from rosenberg it came from
trop it came from um from goebbels
and from a number of others like that
and um
the reason that i say the hitler um
i really comply with this this pressure
was the fact that his line so far of
being the german again going back to
this notion that jews would somehow be
hostages against the um against the
uh non-intervention in the war of the
usa
he held to that of this station in in
september 1941 was now
persuaded that um
the german jews should be uh
deported from to the to the east where
of course genocide was
was already raging and hitler had taken
the view to then the jewish the
so-called jewish question was solved
after the war
but of course he thought the war was
about to be over
by september 1941 it was plain
becoming increasingly plain the war
would not be over
within the five months that he'd um
thought would be given to the war in the
east
that it would take longer and this was
it was
this was the the hitler's thinking when
people were saying well now
we need to let's deport the uh
the the right jews now to the east uh
despite the fact the war is continuing
so hitler then agreed to that
it's not of course a sense of hitler
wanting to retain the jews at all but it
was simply this
tactical device that the jews will be
hostages and then will be
eventually removed after the war and now
uh
the the war is continuing into the
indefinite future and therefore he
agrees to
have the move at this point
i'm gonna take three more cards i
apologize to people
there are a lot of questions here
one of hitler's general's wives i don't
know
about whom this question or speaking
spoke against hitler's policies
do we have any evidence of influence of
lives on
german leaders
influence of wives on german leaders
did they contribute did they support
today
oh i think i mean the the the the
the wives of the the nazi entourage were
highly supportive of course and you look
at something like magda goebbels
who was um every bit as um
as fanatical as her husband was in this
right down to the point where of course
at the end in
the bunker scene they agree that there
will be
there is no life after the death of the
fuhrer
nor should there not could be any life
for their children and uh they
they poison their six children so
um in that case you have a wife who only
eggs on
her husband and this is the case i think
with
uh with with the other wives of the nazi
entourage that they are supportive but
in general terms
i don't think there's a great deal of
evidence that people needed pushing or
prodding from their wives to do the
things that they did
did they need their support which is
different than pushing them
did they need their support um
or were they used as a kind of support
in the camps when they would bring the
wives and children sometimes to live
with them
um i don't
really think that was i i don't know
enough to be able to comment on that
question actually precisely um i know
what what i think you do find amongst
the
these nazi leaders that they they have a
capacity as you see in the
case of the uh commandant of auschwitz
huss then to go back to his wife and
have a normal cream tea
and see the the wife and family as a
type of
psychological uh
psychological compensation or resort
anyway from the abnormality of the
of the daily existence but i wouldn't
like to generalize too much i think i
i don't know enough about the behavior
of the
nazi wise really to be able to speak
with any authority on that particular
point
two more questions ordinary germans
living in the nazi era claimed
at least many of them claimed they knew
nothing about the holocaust
is their ignorance true or honest
and i guess one could ask that question
in light of the klemperer diaries where
he's living
in germany certainly doesn't have more
information than anybody else
and he seems to know an incredible
amount so what do you think
well i think i think that
knowledge or awareness of what was going
on
works in in different ways for different
people and maybe can be seen in certain
senses in concentric circles so it's
knowledge about
what if you're saying knowledge about
the entirety of what was going on then i
think very few people
would have had such a knowledge what was
happening was so
incomprehensible of course also to many
of the victims at the time
people in the warsaw ghettos didn't
actually believe what was
happening not very far away from them so
there's one thing is actually uh
knowledge
um in in a hard sense another is a
a feeling that terrible things are
happening
but you're not absolutely certain of the
details so i think the sense that
dreadful things were happening in the
east was quite
widespread and pervasive the detailed
knowledge of what was happening was much
more limited and then you can say
within that you can look at certain
areas and say the knowledge of that was
far greater than the knowledge of
something else so that for example the
shooting the mass
shootings by the iron's arts group and
on the is commandos
i think knowledge of that was actually
pretty widespread and many people
shut their ears to this knowledge they
knew many people knew
what they didn't want to know and they
turned away from it deliberately or
subconsciously
but people were coming back from the
front um
soldiers and so on reporting things
they'd seen with their very own eyes
these were more than the rumors there
was sometimes hard evidence about what
people had seen
um then later on of course there were
rumors circulating about
about guessing of the jews particular
guest
vans and so on and some of these rumors
were then
attributed to and indeed it was the case
they were
that the news that these were spread by
the bbc for example and
of course then some people said well
that's of course typical propaganda
but nonetheless there's enough evidence
to suggest there in the
for example the reactions of the catin a
discovery in april 1943 demonstrate all
at once there's a little
flash of light on on popular attitudes
towards
uh the treatment of the jews and people
are saying well
um okay the the russians have murdered
these people encountering but look what
we've done to the jews so
these sorts of ideas
these sort of expressions give a little
glimmer of light
into the fact that knowledge of this was
far more widespread
than um than often people
later on were prepared to admit to but
as i said i think we have to
be cautious a little bit in saying what
was this knowledge it was it a
general fading of terrible things
happening sometimes with
some hard evidence about mass shootings
and so on
or was it by knowledge do we mean
a complete understanding of what we
subsequently know happened
the the total nature of the
this colossal genocidal attempt by the
nazis
so i think if you're looking for the
latter then
much of the comment is is honest that we
didn't know
of the scale of this and so on and also
that people didn't know many of the
details but of course
it is the case that the knowledge of
what was going on even the direst
aspects
was more widespread than subsequently
people were prepared to admit to
thank you so much for being here and
thank you for your not only monumental
work but absolutely great read
as peter has said thank you very much
for being here
you